>> Hi, I'm Majid Abraham and, uh, I'm answering
at Davos the key
question which is what countries can do to
improve the world.
Every country shares the same, uh, challenge
that if they do correctly
they can definitely improve the status of
their population in the
world and that is education.
Umm, but we also know that there are a lot
of different standards of
education across the different countries and
in particular there is a
lot of, uh, points of views that are very
different across the
countries.
And what would be really interesting is to
create ultimately some kind
of a forum for young students, uh, maybe selected
by a process like
"American Idol" but would be "The Davos Idol"
or would be "The World
Idol," uh, where, umm, the local TV programs
would take very -- would
take interest in the competition at the local
level and we will also
cover it in terms of what happens at the global
level and it would
serve as a mechanism to, uh, share a, uh -- share
a dialogue and
eventually hopefully share a common point
of view on the challenges,
uh, that the world, uh, faces, uh, what the
different countries, uh,
can do but mostly to help, uh -- to help make
the, uh, the opinions
and the ideas that are available in different
countries, uh, become
more harmonious and to learn about what, uh,
other people consider as
important.